the Last of Us part 2 is a very intense
game but after 2 playthroughs one of
which was on the survivor difficulty I
decided it wasn't enough using a slew of
difficulty settings and HUD options I
set out to make the most intense post
post-apocalyptic experience possible
here's everything I did and exactly how
it turned out so before I begin a few
disclaimers one there will be absolutely
no story spoilers in this video that
said I'll be showing footage from a
bunch of different locations so if you
haven't played the last of his part 2
and you want to go in blind bookmark
this video and come back later to I do
not recommend trying this until you've
completed the game at least once a new
game + save should make this slightly
easier 3 I feel like I have to say this
anytime I make a video about difficulty
but play the game however you like think
of this video as a weird experiment
where I punish myself and you get to
watch sounds like a blast right alright
so with that out of the way let's start
with difficulty when you select new
game+ from the main menu you'll be
greeted with 5 difficulty options and a
custom + difficulty setting the first
thing you'll notice is that all
difficulties in new game+ are harder
than the original settings by default
instead of picking survivor + though I'm
gonna choose custom + this will allow me
to tweak almost all the difficulty
settings right from the get-go I decided
to set almost everything to survivor +
in the name of science however I think
there are a few difficulty options we
can manipulate here and there and still
retain an intense experience so I'm
gonna break down my reasoning behind
each setting the first option titled
player is self-explanatory this largely
determines how much damage Elly can take
I crank this up to survivor because I
think the player needs to be fragile for
this to really work after all most
people can only really take one bullet
before they die or bleed out
I also turned enemies up to survivor
plus because the AI can be rather dumb
otherwise this will hopefully force us
to think critically before killing an
enemy or alerting a guard like enemies I
also set stealth to survivor Plus
because once again the enemies can be
kind of clueless by design
next resources I tuned this up to
survivor Plus as well because I'd
imagine that most if not all the areas
that Ellie visits have been picked clean
now the Allies difficulty option is one
I think we can play with the lower
difficulty you pick the more aggressive
your companions will be I ended up
choosing moderate yes this will make
things easier but I actually kind of
find it unrealistic when my AI buddies
aren't doing [ __ ] DITA grew up in this
world so she should be as capable as
Ellie now that that's taken care of
let's head to the options menu and tweak
the HUD for gameplay I turned everything
off except the weapon cross reticles
damage indicators awareness indicators
hitmarkers health and weapon bars all
gone as I'm writing this I already know
that turning off reticles entirely is a
mistake but what the hell you guys
probably want to see me suffer
anyway if you do decide to try this at
home I think it's important to have the
weapon and ammo display turned off
though because it forces you to count
your bullets which adds a fun little
deadly minigame
also running out of ammo in the middle
of a firefight and hearing a click is
not only exhilarating but if an enemy
hears that they will rush you it's neat
and also terrifying as for notifications
I turn everything off except the pickup
and interaction prompts because those
can be easy to miss otherwise after
tweaking the HUD and difficulty the only
thing missing is the ability to turn off
listen mode if we're trying to make this
game as intense as possible then I don't
think Elly should have an ability that
lets her see through walls if I had to
guess I'd say that if Naughty Dog
decides to add a grounded mode
difficulty setting like they did with
the original it will probably do away
with listen mode but in the meantime I'm
just gonna refrain from holding r1 now
it's time to play to be honest the first
few hours of this game weren't all that
hard even with all the absurd
restrictions I put on myself
this shouldn't be all that surprising
since it's mostly just tutorial sections
with smaller stealth focused encounters
most of the infected can be taken out
silently and if you startle them their
groups are usually pretty small however
there are two things that concerned me
nearly every drawer I opened was empty
and lining up headshots without a
reticle ain't easy when I did a grounded
playthrough of the first last of us
headshots were crucial because that was
the only way you could take down an
enemy in one shot and most of the time
you only had a bullet or two to spare if
I can't land headshots confidently with
the few bullets I have then my unscoped
guns will truly be a last resort
fortunately because I've played through
the game three times now I have upgraded
all my guns to completion and unlock to
every single perk this should hopefully
give me a bit of an edge
after completing this tutorial and the
first few encounters I arrived in
downtown Seattle this is where things
got a bit more interesting well most of
these encounters are still fairly simple
it was a bit more dynamic not only did I
have more tools and weapons at my
disposal but I could approach most of
these scenarios in different ways that
being said I mostly leaned towards the
stealthy approach taking out enemies as
quietly as I could if I got noticed then
I'd run saving my precious bullets for
when an infected got close enough for me
to confidently shoot this actually ended
up working better than expected for two
reasons
first it was unsurprisingly much easier
to line up headshots when enemies were
close second if I did land a body shot I
could follow up with a melee attack to
get the kill unfortunately if I missed
the shot it usually meant I was dead
most of these encounters ended up being
a tense and beautiful mess the moment
I'd get spotted I'd have a split second
to react and form a plan what do I have
what can I use and how can I expend the
least amount of materials possible it's
these moments that make the last of us
part twos combat feel like a frantic
violent puzzle than a cinematic zombie
action game of course this is the last
of us so the action is still cinematic
as heck and zombie as heck but boy does
it really get your heart pumping there's
also an added layer of dread after each
successful combat encounter knowing that
you have less resources and ammo for the
next fight I've never been more mad at
myself for missing a shot than when I
miss a shot in this game survivor mode
also makes you appreciate bricks and
bottles so much more not only are they
good for distracting enemies but if you
hit an enemy with a brick or a bottle
they stagger serving them up for an easy
kill I always made sure I had a brick or
bottle to spare now dealing with the
infected is one thing but the wlf
requires a totally different approach
after the downtown Seattle section you
are greeted not so pleasantly by a
Raider faction known as the WLF or
wolves the important thing to know here
is that they have guns and much better
aim than I do without a reticle landing
headshots or even just regular shots at
a distance is basically impossible
anyway guns are pretty much useless on
the WLF unless you get close which is
tough to do or if they are scoped rifle
ammo in this
is probably the most valuable ammo type
because it's the only weapon I can use
accurately oh also the bow is absolutely
useless without a reticle like seriously
throw it in the trash because you don't
need it the other thing I noticed
through the WLF is that they are a lot
more aggressive on this difficulty
setting a lot of people were saying that
the AI in this game is dumb and I see
why Benny would think that sure they
don't always respond appropriately
during stealth sections but when they
know where you are they are aggressive
as heck they flanked me nearly every
chance thank God you can't really stay
behind cover and pick off enemies from
afar either even if you're much smarter
than me and leave the reticle on because
enemies will constantly pressure and
flank you honestly the aggressive AI is
probably one of my favorite things about
the survivor difficulty every single
enemy feels like a threat and if you're
outnumbered which is most of the time
you really have to strategize and plan
your moves and only a few seconds and
just like the first game if you get
overwhelmed running is a totally viable
strategy you still have to be strategic
though enemies have pinpoint accuracy
and Ellie can't take that many hits this
means that you need to know where you
plan on running to and how much cover
you'll have typically I try to quietly
take out as many wfs as I could and when
things went to [ __ ] I just run it hurts
knowing that you may have left behind
important resources that could help you
at the next encounter
but sometimes running was my only option
but I think that's the beautiful thing
about playing on Survivor you're forced
to make dozens of small decisions every
few minutes that could greatly impact
your next encounter and the rest of your
playthrough do you craft a Molotov or a
first-aid kit should you use a bullet on
this guy or should you sneak around
10:00 on the easier difficulties you
don't really have to think about these
things because resources are common and
you can kill most enemies with ease
well I don't think a brutal experience
like this one is necessary to enjoy the
last of his part - I do think it creates
an interesting challenge that forces the
player to make tough gameplay decisions
that could have interesting
repercussions later down the road if
you're looking for an excuse to do
another playthrough I recommend giving
this a shot
also the bloater fight on Survivor and
the other fight in the hospital in the
second half you either know exactly what
I'm talking about or you'll know
[Music]
you